literary rebels in Northern Mali say
they have seized control of two military
bases in the town of Fleury near the
border with Mauritania violence has
escalated since U.N peacekeeping troops
began withdrawing from the north the
pull out was demanded by mali's Junta
coup leaders say they're considering
mobilizing reservists and have called
off Independence Day Celebrations next
week
while turret rebels in the north of Mali
want autonomy for the desert region they
call azawad that concerned the pull out
by U.N peacekeepers will allow mali's
military to seize areas given up in a
ceasefire agreed in 2015.
is a specialist of defense and security
issues and principal at Jane's which
provides open source Intelligence and
Analysis he joins us from Bordeaux in
France thank you very much for being on
Al Jazeera first of all can you just
outline how dangerous the situation is
right now
uh thank you uh the situation is
definitely degrading the Malian military
as uh apparently experienced several
setbacks and these issues uh against
these armed militant groups uh which uh
were signatories to the Alger the course
of 2015 add to uh the problems that Mali
is facing with the jihadist groups the
fact that Timbuk2 is encircled in a
state of blockade and cannot be
resupplied so it definitely feels that
the Malian military is in a back foot as
it has not been seen since 2013 and it's
very hard to say where the situation is
going to go but it's definitely a cause
for concern and there is a high
probability that things will get just
worse as the U.N withdrawal triggered or
helped trigger this latest round of
fighting
well I I think it started before it was
the I think the French withdrawal was
the first Catalyst because the French uh
were very effectively targeting uh uh on
the jihadist groups and uh were seen as
an important guarantor of uh the respect
of the algers Accord by the uh toward
militant groups in the north and uh so
the the departure of the French which
was met with the degree of incredulity
by some of the the toward groups uh
already started uh this what we're
seeing now and this was only aggravated
by the departure of the U.N it should do
remember that the U.N never had a
mandate to enforce peace and they didn't
have an offensive mandate they were
there uh to act as a stabilization Force
so their ability to carry out operation
against on groups with limited but their
presence alone helped uh keep things in
check I would say right and how are the
groups fighting the I mean I mean are
they working together or are they
fighting each other at the same time
no it's uh it's a very complex situation
uh the jihadists are definitely doing
their own thing and fighting each other
the Islamic State in the grand Sahara is
fighting uh the support group for Islam
and Muslims which is an Al-Qaeda
affiliate meanwhile uh the secular uh
tuarig armed groups uh are that have
made it very clear that they're not
connected in any way with the jihadists
and uh these groups are divided between
those that are still somehow connected
and loyal to banako and those that are
against it and on top of that you have
of course the the malinama forces so
it's quite a complicated setting they're
obviously much much deeper issues here I
mean can this conflict be solved only
through military means at this stage do
you think
I don't think so I I think the the Deep
seated issue is the feeling of
marginalization that uh the north of
Mali has always uh had with regard to
the South uh and uh that uh the issues
are much to do with security as well as
socio-economic uh development and the
lack of uh recognition of these uh
problems by the central government and
this is not something new this is
something that has been going on one way
or another for the past 60 years and the
militaristic approach which consists of
Simply you know tackle issues uh with
Force as hasn't worked and doesn't feel
that it could work in the future given
the situation okay thank you so much
that is Iran de teresi a specialist of
defense and security issues thanks so
much for your time